one two one two
e
good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the overview and scrutiny committee I
will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement there are no
planned fire drills so if the alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via your nearest fire
exit please use either the fire exit
through the main doors of the hall or
the fire exit to the store room adjacent
to the stage the fire assembly point is
the island in front of the main entrance
of the building please do not delay to
the your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio
recorded please switch off mobile phones
and turn them to silent toilet and hand
washing facilities are available in the
foyer members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please speak clearly
into the microphone in front of you
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the audio
recording members voting will be done in
a show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for then against recommendation
and we'll also ask for a show of hands
for those wishing to abstain from voting
so members uh agenda item number one
apologies for absence members we have
received apologies for absence from
councelor Mrs Jane paage councelor Gary
Meers and councelor James goodin and
councelor Eileen uh sorry councelor Miss
gadston members are there any other
apologies of absence nobody is
indicating thank you members agenda item
number two substitute members
uh councelor Daniel FY for councelor Mrs
gadston councelor Richard Lyon for
councelor Mrs Sarah Jane
page any other substitutes no that's
fine agenda item number three non
members attending members I would like
to welcome councelor Lisa newort
attending to tonight's meeting also
councelor M goodin I would also like to
welcome acting Chief Inspector Mr David
Keeley agenda item four minutes of of
the meeting held on the 2nd of November
2023 members are the minutes
agreed agreed thank you agender item
five to receive Declarations of Interest
are there any members please raise your
hands if there
are nobody's indicating thank you
members I would like to now move from
the chair to bring the CSP item to the
top of the agenda to the first item can
I ask for a second off for that proposal
please thank you very much counselor Mrs
belon and can I ask for a vote please
members thank you
members sorry C
counselor um was that first item to vote
for or uh it's to move uh the second
item the CSP to the top of the agenda my
only thoughts really are that um uh in
chief chief inspector David Key can then
um leave the meeting rather than take up
his valuable time that's fine I just
wonder whether the first vote was for y
as it normally is yes yeah are there any
members
against no thank you any members
abstaining no thank
you bear with me so um agenda item
number seven is now um the first item on
our agenda I will now invite the
executive lead member for communities
and health uh councelor Lisa Newport to
introduce this
report thank you
chair Community safety partnership this
report updates the committee on the
delivery of the joint Castle point and
Rochford District Community safety
partnership priorities and actions each
year The Joint Community Partnership
provides an update with a statut
Duty and
sorry report I've lost my lost my
place each year The Joint Community
safety partnership provides an update
report to the committee on its work for
the year in line with the statutory Duty
under Section six of the crime and
disorder act 1998 the community safety
partnership produces the implements and
partnership plan for reducing crime and
antisocial
Behavior the budget for 232 4 is
allocated as detailed in the report and
the partnership are pulling together the
Strategic assessment and risk Matrix
with the annual report and partnership
plan due in March next year crime
figures included in report are showing
reduction in antisocial behavior and
hate crime unfortunately Jonathan
woodams the corporate manager for
Community safety cannot be at this
meeting tonight but we do have Steve
Summers the Strategic director and
inspector uh Dave key here to respond to
any questions that you may have
thank you um so members you've got the
report there item seven the community
safety partnership report uh members
would you like to indicate if you would
like to ask any questions um to our
officer the p uh the lead member or
Chief Inspector David
Keeley uh councelor Mrs
Belton thank you um this is probably to
the the Chief Inspector but may cross
over um item uh 1.3 within the report
highlights five um main areas of um
attention essentially item three is
antisocial Behavior item five is hate
crime um we've had a lot of issues
across certainly hotley and ra um in
recent months with graffiti specifically
um racist graffiti but lots of
antisocial behaviors and so on um item
six of the report refers to the
Partnerships and the authorities that
you speak to including local authorities
and County councils so my first question
is really do does that include parish
and town councils to ensure that we're
picking up all the relevant information
so that the statistics are suitably um
collected and that we're not duplicating
resources and
information
yes it it does it does okay and what are
we doing to ensure and if I may just
follow on from that question what are we
doing to ensure that all of these crimes
are um reported because the statistics
state that they're coming down which is
fantastic but our um probably our
observations are that that's possibly
not the case and it may be that some of
these crimes are not being reported
through the correct channels because
people don't like to waste police time
is there anything more that we can do to
encourage residents and encourage our
parish councils as well I don't think so
no I think we're trying to we we do a
lot of community meetings we try and
engage as many people as possible
certainly with har community Community
we've got really good engagement with
them there was a massive Under reporting
from them in the past um and now whilst
they're not always supportive of going
forward they will report things to us um
so I think it has improved in those
areas but it's just trying to increase
the confidence of people to try and get
them to speak with us and tell us what's
going on then that we certainly do as
much as we can within the community to
have those engagement events get into
the
schools um and try to encourage that and
that's part of our messaging that we put
out okay thank you thank you chair thank
you um councelor um lambor
please yeah sorry I guess this question
is really for the officers um in
1.4 we state that we get a grant of
£1,300 and then you list various um
projects that that money goes towards is
there any way that we can have a
breakdown of what is spent on each
individual
item and over the and I believe you've
we've had the
same um grant for several years is there
any um information going backwards on
each year how much has been
spent thank you I think um our officer
Mr suers will answer that
one thank you chair yeah we can
certainly look into that and provide
that back to the committee in terms of
how it is actually broken down in terms
of detail um and we can circulate that
round to
everybody thank you is that okay thank
you very much um councelor mil
please uh yeah this question would
probably be for councel of Newport but
obviously we can uh the others can chip
in it's about the statutory membership
of the community safety
partnership um when I was uh an observer
on when I was in Ry Town council's
chairman uh or or on a committee we were
invited in but we didn't have a vote on
it so the parishes didn't have a vote on
the community safety partnership but the
districts do um regarding the statute
members are there is there any figures
of any of the do all the statutory
Partners attend every meeting I know the
police do because they're absolutely key
to it uh do we get um I don't know one
of the larger organizations being
missing from time to time is that in the
minutes do they all attend NHS and the
rest of
them thank you are there any any
information on that councelor Mrs new I
can answer part of it for you councelor
m um R Town Council do have an invite to
each meeting and I was just advised that
they don't take up the the seat they
don't they they they don't attend um
with regards to the other part of the
question I'll pass you over to Steve who
will hopefully be able to answer you
yeah so in terms of the statutary
partners that as you say they are
statutary they are all invited what we'd
have to do is we'd have to go back and
look through the minutes to to answer
your query around who attends and who
doesn't attend um I think the report
actually does refer to a sort of
refreshing the partnership because
obviously it's with Castle Point um and
we held a workshop meeting in November
where we're trying to encourage people
to come and I think as part of that we
will do that but again I can dig into
that information and circulate around to
to members so they're aware uh yeah that
that's what I I really just wanted to
ask because I know the police do
tremendous programs in Essex through the
the commissioner off the police and
crime commission is always a project
running he's always got money for that
it's just that when you've got other key
players I particularly remember in the
Met um we had instances of NHS assault
figures Rising but the crime Figures
were going down for that crime type and
there was something not right not
happening there and it was probably to
do with crime reporting which is an
earlier question and U because that
that's the perception of the public you
that kind of thing anyway thank
you thank you um just on the back of
that um please Mr Summoners could we um
have a report on the statutory partners
that do not
attend um for example notoriously
unfortunately the NHS were quite often
absent and yet they can play big role in
the partnership thank you councilor
FY thank you chairman it's just a
clarification when Council new gave her
opening
statements um did she say I think I'm I
might have misheard but you said the um
hate crime
decreased it actually has
increased according to the port show
reduction uh page 7.2 right at the top
uh thank you councilor FD um that was
for the figures for 2122 right
sorry yes okay good good it's on the
decrease thank you any other question um
councel
FD no thank you thank you um councelor
won
thank you madam chairman first of all
congratulations to uh the lead member
for Community safety and officers for
the compilation of this report excellent
report um now police numbers in Essex
are at their highest record numbers at
around the 3,700 Mark um but uh um we
know that policing has become much more
diverse uh and much more demands on
placing time uh compared with the years
of uh uh Dixon of Doc Green's days so we
understand um yes I'm old enough to
remember Dixon of Doc green um but uh I
look at the list at
1.3 and often the reason why we don't
see so many police on the streets is
because of the diverse nature of
policing and often the growth in cyber
crime uh is used as an example of where
there is much more resource needed and
yet and it is a little topical after the
very excellent presentation last night
um but uh it is noticeable that there's
no mention of cyber crime uh and
particularly victims of cyber crime and
I would like to suggest that that is
taken account of in the future plan I
realize that those are the objectives
for uh 20 22 to 23 um but moving forward
I would have thought that cyber crime
was sufficiently important victims of
cyber crime fraud and and and and like
uh could be there so that's a point
there may be an answer on that and if I
may Madam chairman um certainly it's one
for the lead member and certainly for
officers that sitting a little outside
of this but nevertheless relevant for
public protection and Community safety I
would like to ensure that there is still
provision uh locally for there to be
initiatives um by Parish councils the
Town Council um and indeed ourselves to
carry on with uh Community safety
initiatives so that we actually
um devolve responsibility uh to all
levels of of local government if they
identify they want an additional light
flood light or something that there is
money in the pot to be able to provide
that under the Community safety fund
thank you madam
chairman thank you uh councilor won um
would anybody like to come back on how
the CSP priorities are identified
because that would help answer Council
warton's question around cyber
crime thank you chair so um yeah you are
quite right in in terms going back to
what I said previously the CSP has been
refreshed and they are looking at their
priorities he talks about that within
the report and I think going forwards
that's um the priorities are based on
the stats that provide as as you've seen
within the report but there's no reason
why when we go back to the next CSP
working group we can mention that as
cyber crime and see if they're
interested in taking that forward
normally what happens and I think it's
in here about prevent response promote
when thereby below that would sit a load
of categories but again I will take that
back and then feed it back to the
members of the
committee thank you uh councelor Mrs
Mason thank you chair um I'd like to
follow up slightly with a slight
variation on comments that have been
made by uh councelor Belton and I'd also
like to Echo what council won said about
the report I think it's an excellent
report and it's nice to see such a
comprehensive one um what concerns me
slightly and this is addressed to the
acting Chief Inspector is there's an
apparent reduction in crime which we
have touched on
um
but what we used to be advised and I
don't and if you can correct me if this
is now changed that the level of
policing was perhaps not in direct
correlation but certainly in correlation
to some degree on the amount of crime
reported so I'm assuming that is still
to some degree correct but what the
issues that I have found and I've heard
is the difficulty and the time taken in
reporting
crimes
also residents have commented that when
they are reporting a crime they're not
necessarily being given a crime
reference number and I'm talking about
lowlevel CL crime here but low-level
crime can obviously escalate and
low-level crime to my mind needs to be
addressed to prevent escalation so what
I would like to ask you is what methods
of reporting do you have how do you
determine whether or not to give a crime
reference
number and what can you do to encourage
residents to report crimes because I
appreciate that you're going into
schools but from what we're reading and
what we're hearing sometimes don't match
up so I I think the level of reporting
needs to be addressed and I don't know
how you're going to do that so I'd like
to hear thank you um we have a whole
contact management command so it's not
down to the local areas uh we have a
single online home system so you can do
it online and Report um and it goes into
a contact center who
then sift the information and figure out
is there a crime isn't there a crime if
we think there's a crime we we have to
we have like a whole National Crime
recording standards and they audit every
single one that comes in every single
job that comes in to make sure if
there's anywhere on there that we might
have missed where something should have
been a crime it gets
with technology and it's taken some
bedding in I think is the is a good way
to put it um however they are going
through a massive restructure to try and
make it even better to try and get our
incident lists down and to sift what's
important what's not and get things
primmed quicker to stop those delays
because there are delays and they know
it's not right and they're working
really really hard to to get it right
but I mean I'm talking for a command
that I have absolutely nothing to do
with other than and they tell me where
to go and what to allocate to my staff
so thank you if I me just come back M so
if it's if the report is identified as
um comprising a CL crime will a crime
reference number be given to that report
and will it be communicated to the
person that's reporting it yes they
automatically fire off a letter and an
email and it's like a it's an automated
system and it sends a letter saying this
is your crime reference number and they
will get
that may I suggest that perhaps a simple
we've got online and we've got telephone
which is not brilliant um perhaps a
simple publicity thing that we can
perhaps through the council consider um
publicizing for you because we we have
access amongst us to various social
media groups to various communication
groups and I I do think there is a lack
of General awareness
and certainly when it comes to telephone
the time taken is relatively excessive
and I think that's why some aren't
reported to yourself they just and we do
try and steer people away from the
phones now to the new single online home
system for that very reason because
people were getting so frustrated with
it but I I do think our messaging we do
put it out on all our messaging to try
and make but our reach is is limited
isn't it so I do think support from
Partners around that messaging would be
greatly appreciated I'm sure Council
Newport would assist in getting messages
out and I'm sure we would but um online
yes telephone not so good but we've got
quite a lot of elderly people who
perhaps aren't familiar with the online
reporting system so perhaps even the
oldfashioned letter might come in handy
I don't know but I'd like that to be
explored so that the elderly or less
technical able all of our residents
aren't excluded from reporting in a Time
F absolutely the letter isn't automatic
gener isn't automatically generated I
don't think that's well known but thank
you thank you for coming
back thank you um councelor Mrs Mason uh
councelor
sparin thank you chairman um again for
acting Chief Inspector along the similar
lines to councilor Mrs
Mason while I it's encouraging people
are reporting more in in my experience
there is still a complete lack of any
comeback as to what people have reported
on
occasions um I've been on the pointed
end of this on several occasions
particularly in relation to drug related
issues um I've chased up three weeks
later six weeks later nothing um it was
quite a serious issue um but I think
people get disheartened and in the end
they'll end up just saying well there's
no point I'm not saying you didn't do
anything but it would have just been
nice say thanks for the information um
you know we're acting on it even as
simple as that or just an email to say
your information has been been noted we
are dealing with it thank you no I agree
and every time something is reported we
put something called a p on which is a
police information report and they are
then gathered and the more we get those
we can then get warrants and then we can
do warrants on addresses and that's how
we operate now that's how all
are generated so they are hugely
important um and I can I'll feed that
back to contact management Commander if
you're reporting stuff then we should be
saying thanks and letting you know that
we are doing something with it because a
crime reference number would be
generated in a letter for an actual
crime but for intelligence an
intelligence report is generated but you
won't always get told what's going on
with that because of the nature of what
we're planning on doing with it but you
should still get something to
acknowledge I feel but I'll I'll feed
that back
very thank you uh councelor Booth uh
thank you madam chairman I just like to
go to 7.3 the paragraph right at the top
of that page uh training on hidden harms
provided to all taxi and private hire
drivers all taxi license holders have
improved awareness I was just wondering
what's the evidence for making such a
statement and how is that
measured thank chair so um
I did speak to uh my colleague today
regarding um that particular training
and whilst the training is delivered um
through to the taxi license holders um
the actual way of quantifying the
success or otherwise of that is very
difficult to to put into uh an approach
I suppose as best I can put it so the
trouble is is that whilst that Train's
given there's no recognized method
of understanding how how the outcomes of
that may
be yes of course you can yeah thank you
madam chairman just wondering if there
could be some self- evaluation after the
training that measures the taxi driver's
knowledge before the hour two hours
training and their knowledge after two
hours of training that would provide
some at least hard data to reassure us
it's just not a statement plugged from
the
air yeah that's and that's good thought
and we can certainly do
that
I have another question I'm told Madam
chair I can see your bit of paper right
okay thank you so I just wondering then
obviously this is very important to our
local residents it's the one thing that
they do talk to us about as counselors
uh especially all those outside bodies
were on I think it's one of the most
prominent ones that there is for us to
attend so I'm just wondering how do
members of the council receive
information about this and how a report
circulated
I'll pass it over to Steve if I may
sorry can can you just repeat the
question I'll forget the Preamble and go
straight to the question so how do
members of the council receive
information on the uh CSP meetings and
our report
circulated so as far as I'm aware
they're not circulated um but I think
certainly going forward with the refresh
and our new approach to the the CSP
that's something we can look at and I
think we could circulate something to
members that comes out as a result of
the CSP
meetings so I think that's two really
positive steps that we do have self-
evaluation after courses so we can
measure things to see about uh improved
awareness and also that reports are
circulated thank
you thank you Council of both um Council
a
ward thank you chairman uh there was one
question I had but as councelor Booth
actually bought up U that item that top
item just an item with regard to the cab
drivers uh London black cab drivers have
a special relationship with the Met
where they are the eyes and ears and
keep things open maybe that's something
else that should be in the training and
some kind of interaction between the
local cab firms and their employees and
the the local police because it just
adds to the number numers that that are
likely to be able to help as they're
going along it happens in London all the
time so why shouldn't it happen here if
I carry on with my main question now um
it's it's just basically uh to do with
some of the items in 1.6 you know you
got project maneuver and you got safer
streets now this was just an idea that
we had I think it was about six seven
years ago that we put uh to the police
at the time in regard cars to where they
Park their cars now in Ry they Park all
their cars in the back of the car park
and we suggested because you don't have
boots on the ground or not as many as
people want to see you could do a little
bit of kidology so to speak and you
could park a car in the High Street at
least it would give the impression that
maybe there is a couple of officers who
happen to be patrolling we're looking at
safer streets and it's just a kidology
of basically saying look look there are
police about cars parked there in one of
the Lys it's a busy night it sounded
sense to me at the time it was thought
about nothing happened so I'm just
putting that one to you as one of the
various bullet points that you could
possibly take on board as something that
you could do which is easy you got loads
of cars in the car park just put one out
there they can go back and have a cup of
tea do whatever work they want to do or
they could actually walk about the
street
thank you
chairman thank you Council Ward I think
that's noted for yeah okay um any other
members indicating councilor M oh this
is really um not so much as a question
but an observation and which Chief
Inspector actually might like to hear
about I had a number of emails from
residents who' had criminal damage to
their houses and cars and they hadn't
had much feedback and that was the
General thing of but I actually had a
suspicion that our Len officer for
officer lamb would have known all about
this so I just sent him a short email
said look I've had these people asking
these
residents and he sent a tailor made
reply back which was suitable for the
residents because it told him a bit
about it but not too much because was
not nothing confidential but in fact
there was a vehicle circulated
nationally and was all sorts of things
because they'd been tracking a team of
nuisances who traveled right through the
area and I was then able to put all of
that straight back his his comment
straight back to those residents and all
has now gone quiet from them because
they're know quite happy that there is
actually investigation because the safer
streets team were on it it's just that
they don't always tell every been
everything they're doing because I mean
it's nature of the job you know um but
yeah that was that was pretty good
feedback and it was very quick very
precise and just did the right thing so
that's the sort of thing we we love
thank you
thank you well that's a big up for um uh
Warren Lan there I think um okay I've
got a few questions if that's okay um
first of all um 5.1 we've already um
spoken about the funding uh Council
lambor brought that up um we need more
funding the pfcc gets more funding now
so could we please Lobby for more
funding so that's that um request then
then looking at um Paton point3 again
talking about the
projects uh the third paragraph talks
about the bar and bus across the
district as per last time this was
mentioned at a meeting I'd love to see
the evidence of where it goes in the
district because I do know it does not
cover the whole of the district very
good project so perhaps we could um see
if it could expand out to reach the
whole of the
District also with regard to the taxi
Marshals bearing in mind the funding
that we have at the moment is less than
13,000 for the whole of the district I'd
like to see or have it investigated how
our nighttime economy could actually
support this project in some shape or
form even if it was only match funding
from where this is
targeted um and
project
manura it would be interesting to know
which pubs bars and clubs aren't
involved only because then we as Ward
counselors if there's any within our
areas we could actually have a chat with
them perhaps get them on board get them
involved in
this um I think that is all of my
questions uh councelor cross you've got
a question uh thank you madam chairman
um yes question to uh the acting uh
Deputy Chief Inspector um now we have
CCTV after many years are waiting for it
in Ry how is that or how is the
monitoring of that communicated to the
local feet on the street is there a a
rapid response team to to act upon
things that are spotted on CCTV we've
got a town center team which is based
within the community policing team uh we
share
sorry we've got a community
okay we've got we've got a town center
team which is based within our community
policing team uh they deal with a lot of
the stuff within the town um and equally
you've got R police station in the High
Street and if a lpt officers available
to go out to anything that's seen
they'll go straight out to it we've got
um a radio that I helped get set up
inside Brentwood offices where it is
monitored and they can go straight onto
our radio Channel and tell us what's
going on live um and it's going to
improve detection and uh prosecution I
would suggest cuz we had a massive
problem with CCTV and we've got really
really really good clear photos and
footage now as you've probably seen so
it's really
positive thank you that's very
reassuring thank
you thank you any final
questions so uh just to summarize um
thank you so much again again um members
have already mentioned um a a nice
concise
report thank you councelor Mrs Newport
for coming along this evening and Mr
suers especially you Chief Inspector
David Keeley please do go away um you've
had the office of help here we are
willing to not only just as a council
but as individual members if there is
anything we can do please just ask thank
you thank you thank you for the
hospitality and switch around of the
agenda as well appreciate it I've made
one person unhappy though cuz he's been
here
longer thank you very much um I know
that you'd like to make a move thank
you so members uh the report was for
noting is that noted
members thank you so if we can go back
now please to agenda item
six I will now invite Tim Willis to give
a very brief overview because the report
is in front of you um Tim will is the
councelor council's interim director of
resources to introduce the
report thank you chair um this is the
second treasury management report for
the financial year um the report
highlights relatively high but Falling
inflation
and relatively
high for falling um interest rates um
this is helping our investments uh the
latest rates earned are around
5% and we forecast a surplus against
budget of £ 489,000 on interest on
investments um which is has been built
into the budget monitoring report for
this year that went to the executive on
the 16th of
November the council has no borrowing um
interest on borrowing would currently
cost in excess of 5% I'm happy to answer
any questions chair thank you thank you
councelor Mrs
Mason to remember this
thing this is just a a small question
really because we have have
the the capital
expenditure and this though this is a
very small amount of capital income the
section 106 money I'm referring to
section 106 I noticed that it has
increased
substantially
and I'm aware that a lot of section 106
money is specific
or time limited
so I'm I I think this is done but I'd
just like to ensure that lead members
are made aware of any money in the
section 106 income that pertains to
their
areas and I think it's done but perhaps
I could have confirmation of that thank
you thank you chair um yes this if there
are schemes in a particular area then
the relevant Ward members as well as any
lead members would be aware of those
section 106s I think the the the area
that is less clear cut is if there's
section 106 money that's been agreed
with developers it's a waiting
allocation um and it will be used to
fund projects but hasn't been identified
and matched to those projects that's
that may not be as transparent and
available to members as once the scheme
is is identified and
approved thank you
thank you uh councelor Mrs Mason uh
councelor
FD thank you chairman
um last meeting these meetings I was out
I asked about the question about the
777 th000 and was kind enough to send me
an email and I was just wondering what's
happened to actually still in the
report thank you chair um yes it is
still there because it's still part of
the council's Capital financing
requirement um I did raise this with
anyone that I could think of internally
and then with our advisor link our
external advisors as to what this
related to because nobody knew um link
said that it probably is very historic
it's a historic
transaction um we don't have any
external bwing so this isn't related to
external borrowing um and it's probably
grounded in some accounting transaction
number of years ago I've um agreed in
principle that I'll commission link to
carry out an investigation to identify
exactly what this is for um it's it's
peculiar because normally a local
Authority that has a capital financing
requirement that sort of implies that it
has external borrowing but rsford does
not have external borrowing um so um it
could be internal borrowing is my guess
but until I know for sure I can't give a
categoric answer to you councilor
and even if you might raise it every
time we have a treasury management
report which is your right um so I'm
toying with the idea of I'm waiting for
link to tell me how much they would
charge to investigate to identify what
this is um and I'll form a view as to
whether or not it's worth doing that if
it's thousands of pounds to do it then
I'll say don't bother but if it's you
know a smaller sum then I would want to
investigate it because it's a an item a
balancing a balance within the council's
accounts that I can't explain to you and
I'm the chief finance officer so that
makes me a little bit uncomfortable even
though it could date back decades and
it's never it's never changed that any
from that figure that anyone can
identify thank you thank you does that
answer your question councelor F yes and
thank you for the answer thank you
councelor Mrs belon just following on
from councelor F's Point um and hearing
everything that you say we're going to
be in a situation next year when Tim
Willis isn't with us
um different counselors could be around
the table and this historic problem if
not resolved becomes someone else's
historic problem with even L information
that you have so I do think it's
important that sort of some urgency is
put on it because every 3 months we're
going to be referring to this line in
the report and you might not be here to
give such a comprehensive answer next
time and it could send new counselors or
any counselors into a a flurry of um
concern because it is a large a large
sum that's un sort of UN accounted for
so to speak so just just a note to say
that I do think some urgency should be
placed on tidying that up even though
hearing that it's probably not an actual
issue just a
reporting thank you councelor Mrs Bon
that have be noted and included in the
minutes uh councilor
won thank you madam chairman um look
this treasury management report is would
be the Envy of many councils around the
uh um country at the present time so
congratulations that it reflects the
stability of our finances um and may
that long be the case um but um
certainly on one side we've got
fortuitous um increase in interest
returns that's good news but of course
the council is subject on the other side
of the equation to inflation and all the
things that that brings um particularly
on 3.1 uh I note on the fourth bullet
point absolutely correct um that is the
latest figure which is published through
the G7 uh and I accept that's August uh
but I do think when this report goes to
full Council it would be helpful to have
an upto-date uh inflation figure uh and
uh we're talking uh you know the figures
for October have now been published
4.7% uh so the fifth bullet point could
be updated uh with the up to- dat figure
um and it may even be by the time
actually it won't be by the time the
publication of the council agenda um but
certainly um I was thinking the G7 may
have even updated their figures from
August but certainly it would be quite
nice to see an updated bullet point
there thank you uh thank you councilor
won um I don't think that will be
possible as we are voting on this one
tonight to go to full Council next week
am I correcting that thank you very much
thank you um any other members
indicating thank you so um members there
is one recommendation set out page 6.1
of the report that the committee notes
the council's treasury activities for
the period ending 30th September
2023 before is presented to for Council
on the 14th of December as this is going
to for Council I do have to ask for a
vote so those members in favor please
raise your
hands those me thank you those members
against please raise your hands
and those members ofing please raise
your
hands thank you
members that is
carried moving on to agenda item eight
the regulatory investigative Powers Act
um Ripper members I will now invite the
executive lead member for communities
and health counselor Mrs Lisa Newport to
introduce this report thank you chair
the purpose of this report is to update
members on the use of Ripper over the
past year and to allow for the review of
the council's Ripper policy members will
note that there has been Neil use of
ripper in the last year and that the
Ripper policy has been reviewed and
there are no amendments to consider
other than a change of offices which
have been reflected and amended
accordingly thank you councelor Mrs Port
um members are there any questions
councelor
M um well this one comes up most years
because we haven't used Ripper for years
basically is there can anyone give an
indication of an example where it might
actually be used by the
council thank
you there's a good reason why it doesn't
get used very much or at all you're
quite right counselor um my experience
of where has been used in the past where
um I've worked at different authorities
is normally around fraud um so if if
there's fraud cases where the normal um
information can't be provided in an open
transparent way then Ripper may be used
but it's it's very very rare you're
right right thank you thank you are
there any other questions
members no there isn't so this is just
so members this is just for noting is
that noted
members thank you thank you councelor
Mrs
newort
members moving on to agenda item nine
the review of the council's outside
bodies um so members a brief update
report has been provided detailing the
progress to date on the review of the
outside bodies task and finish group met
in the summer following which I spent
some time with officers to complete a
scoping document for the work which was
approved by the committee a survey has
um recently been sent out to all members
around which um outside IES they have
been appointed to how active these have
been and how beneficial they feel they
are to the
council lead members have also been
asked to provide details of any outside
bodies that they have attended work is
ongoing by the officers to Cate details
of other ethics authorities appointments
to outside bodies and how their members
report back on outside body activity a
more detailed report will come to this
committee outlining the results from the
outside body review with' recommend
ations on future appointments and on
reporting back on outside body
activities this will include things such
as terms of reference of the groups
whether we are a statutory member of
that group therefore have to attend or
whether we are invited that sort of
thing members details of the current
appointments to outside bodies can be
found on Seth and are set out in the
minutes of the meeting held on the 28th
of June in case anybody has a question
on who goes to which meeting at present
the report that comes back to this
Committee in February will set out the
terms of reference for outside bodies
together with frequency of meetings
reporting Etc members are there any
questions on this to
date Council a
ward it's basically an observation
chairman um you're going to set out
various concepts for members who are
going to attend these meetings but I
know from experience at Sanctuary when I
was appointed to the committee and the
board that everything was in PNC and
could not come outside of that meeting
so there may be a difficulty a paradox
so to speak in requiring a report back
from Members where they cannot report
back thank you councilor Ward I will
trust that you have fed this back in the
survey and it will also then correlate
with any other members who attend such
Boards of sanctuary where there is
anything that's PNC and obviously then
that would be part of the final report
that comes back to Council on those sort
of things does that answer your question
y thank you counselor FD uh thank you
chairman when were the because I filled
in the survey a while ago when would the
um information from the survey be
collected because I actually did put an
outside body which doesn't exist at the
moment which I maybe like to have
created so will that go go in there if
it
does um I would I I'm sure it will come
back in the report that somebody has put
down a body that perhaps doesn't exist
it will be down to the officers time and
let them go through it they've also got
to at first Chase up members because not
all ever been perhaps is sufficient or
had the time yet because they've been on
holiday or anything like that to
complete the
survey thank you councilor lambor you've
got a question
in the um list of things that you say
will come back in the report in in um uh
February can it be also split so that we
see which bodies we've actually got
voting rights and management rights on
rather than which wasn't one of the
things that you
listed that that's s of information will
be in the terms of reference for each of
the groups that come back and then
there'll be an overarching I believe
terms of reference for us for the groups
yes yeah they'll be appended to it and a
second question on on the list I do not
a couple of missing that that I'm not on
but I know other people are like um the
finchfield and the um dut Cottage
committees they're not mentioned yeah um
uh Sonia will answer on that one because
it's separate to actually an outside
body I believe because it's a trust hold
them yeah th those th those are actually
sort of charitable trusts and um they
they they've actually got um articles
which which which are very prescriptive
in terms of how those are actually
operated uh Council Lamborn so that
those those would be dealt with
separately but surely there's still an
outside bage I mean they can they should
be part of this report but under a SE
separate section I I I I um I'll make a
suggestion um councelor lambor that
within the rippo other bodies that have
been mentioned such as those trusts are
included an appendix just to give a
brief overview of them and why they're
not included on the outside body's list
is that
okay yeah that that's fine but can I
just um really sort of um plead with the
members to uh to actually communicate
with us with the you with with with with
any organizations which they feel are um
are omitted so that we can include them
we're only as good as the information
that we can Cate thank
you um could I just uh say councelor
lambor and any member if there are other
things that you would like to think are
relevant to this report that you'd like
to feed in after this that come to mind
um you know please do feed that in uh
councelor Mrs
belon Sonia's pretty much covered it as
as have you I just wanted to support the
fact that I think some of these other
bodies that aren't quite the norm should
be included within the wider report for
transparency and for member
understanding but you've you've covered
that off thank
you thank you um any other
members uh council Mrs Mason can I just
ask a question are you intending to rank
or to try and put um an importance value
on the outside bodies or not
I think you're posing quite a difficult
question because we yes we will be going
on the information that we are given by
other members so it may be that it comes
to um a wider debate with this group or
also perhaps with the Constitution
working group um that we have a look at
the importance of our representation on
all of these outes thank
you
councelor cross thank you madam chairman
um yes I have been on holiday and I I
missed that I haven't completed this
survey but I'm pleased to say that I
have attended uh zero as substitute for
councelor
wooden thank you okay members thank you
um so that is literally just an update
for noting um if we move swiftly on to
agenda item number 10 it's the key
decisions document
um if I go through it Page by page if
anybody has anything to raise please say
so page one is literally just the
overview page two has any member please
indicate if you would like to raise
anything on page
two councelor Mrs
Mason I'd like to thank you chair I'd
like to raise a question about the uh K
decisions document I don't think it can
be answered here one of the things that
we have asked for which hasn't so so far
translated is the idea of the key
decision when it's first implemented
then we can then track it to its
completion if we haven't got an
instigation date then we don't know how
long it's been on there so that's one
thing I believe we also asked for the um
lead member to go on there which I'm I'm
pleased to know has been
done
however I am concerned that there are
probably errors of omission on this
document and perhaps I could ask um St
Steve Summers to check with the uh
directors to see if there are any
um items that should be
included
thank you councelor Mrs Mason uh um Mr
suus Could you um follow up on that
please and perhaps report back at the
next meeting certainly can do thank you
uh councelor sparin thank you
chman thank you chairman um getting a
little bit confused chairman because I
see back on the uh key decisions
document uh skate park is now been
reinstated in Clement Hall whereas a few
weeks ago it was missed off or wasn't
being actioned
um perhaps uh we need some clarification
as to where we actually stand on this
skate park thank you
chairman thank you councilor sparin um I
don't know if our officer is able to
respond to that one
tonight
uh certainly councel m m want to respond
yeah I'm quite happy to do so because
I'm aware of this the holbridge and ra
Leisure centers on are progressing but
the Clement H we are waiting for further
information so because they've all been
left on there perhaps it should be split
if that would help thank you um so just
just for
clarity um where in the whole of the
district are skateboard parks going to
be positioned across the whole of the
district I believe it's in the hridge
playing fields we for want of another
description um and at the r Leisure
Center
those are the two that have been
determined Clemens Hall there is an
issue because the original location was
altered and we're having to look at
noise
disturbance so when when there's a
report back on that then we will know
whether it proceeds or how it
proceeds thank you um whoever is leading
on this report perhaps they could also
advised um regarding the south of the
district um is there news on skate parks
in in that
area this this is something that was
carried over from the previous
administration so it's not something
that's been
instigated um from this Administration
and we're trying to make sure that
things that were outstanding are
completed as far as possible so you'll
appreciate I can't answer that question
but as far as I know these are the only
three that were considered thank you
thank you um I councilor belon do you
have a question thank you yeah I have a
question on this one and then a question
on the next so I'll I'll wait for the
next one if that's okay um if I'm not
mistaken and it refers back to earlier
points these skate parks are as a result
of section 106 funding now so that's why
the areas are where the areas are
because they're all related to specific
projects around the district um
development projects the the concern is
what is the deadline for the Clem Hall
skate park because the original sighting
the minute stated that that was approved
and the sighting was okay so I
understand that there's now a change in
that that's being reviewed but deadlines
and and so on and I think it's important
that that is it is important but I think
we're all going down this rabbit hole
which is separate to just um you know
the key questions um that we need to
raise on this key decisions document
chairman I can answer that if it helps
um okay I'm I'm happy to allow that se
106 timing has been
extended I believe but you could check
with the director I'm sure Marcus Hudson
will advise you accordingly thank you I
think that's very helpful thank you very
much councelor Mrs Mason um councelor FY
are you happy now chairman um a question
was answered by councelor
bton thank you uh any other questions on
the key decisions
document thank you very much okay uh
agenda item 11 the work plan
oh
that's okay I was doing doing it by
pages but please pop your microphone and
what's your question regarding the
development of 3G pitches U two two
questions again this is a section6
project that had been determined now
referring back to the planning meeting
of recent a week or two ago um councilor
Hoy referred to a um statement that's
being drafted by the climate emergency
committee I don't believe that's
actually started yet um and again I just
wonder timings we don't want to lose
section 106 money members have all made
the point quite clear tonight and
previously that it's vital that we spend
it rather than lose it so I just want to
understand what's happening with this
item um because based on the planning
meeting it looks like it can't progress
so is there going to be an alteration to
the section 106 money to ensure we don't
lose
it thank you councelor Mrs Bon I can see
our officer gainy writing all this down
so I am sure that he will come back with
some responses for us at the next
meeting if that's okay with the
committee thank you are there any other
questions on the work sorry on the key
decisions document before we move on to
the work
plan thank you members our agenda item
11 the work plan member are there any
questions on the work
plan
nobody is
indicating so everybody is quite content
with what's on the work plane at
present thank you very much then members
that concludes our business for this
evening thank you very much
for